20 million Soviet citizens died at
his hands for a quarter of a century.
He ruled his huge Ambar
with a ruthless iron.
Fist terror was his modus
operandi while he was alive,
no one,
not even his closest
family members were safe.
Yet at his passing,
he was mourn as the savior of his people.
In this week's buying graphics,
we uncover the terrible
truth about Joseph Stalin.
A single death is a tragedy.
1 million deaths is a statistic.
The man who would come to be known as
Joseph Stalin was born in the small
Georgian town of glory.
At the time,
Georgia was part of the
imperial Russian empire.
His date of birth was December the 18th
1878 stolen father of a salary and zero
cash villi.
It was also known as bay,
so he was a shoemaker,
runs also an alcoholic,
or you spend much of his time away from
home producing footwear for the Russian
army.
On his rare appearances at home,
he would beat his wife and son,
Stalin's mother,
Catherine,
Rena,
Aussie meted out punishments on the
boy that was generally protective.
Often Stalin only learn to speak
Russian when he was nine years old and
throughout his entire life.
He never lost his strong
George and accents installing.
He was raised in an
atmosphere of violence.
Gorrie was a rough town with organized
street brawling being a popular pass
time.
On February the 13th 1892 the young
stolen witnessed the public hanging of two
criminals.
The traumatized child came away with
a hatred of the Cyrus regime style it,
and he was sent to a church school
where he excelled academically.
He sang in the church choir
and is impressed as teachers
with his intelligence
and his memory.
In 1894 he graduated two
years ahead of schedule.
Then at the age of 15 he was awarded a
scholarship to the theology seminary in
tiff lists the Georgian capital.
However,
the team was more taken with the
writings of Marx and Engels and the Bible
declaring himself a
Marxist and an atheist.
He joins the Russian Social
Democratic Labor Party or RSD LP.
In 1899 stolen was expelled from the
seminary as a result of his Marxist
leanings.
By now.
He had adopted the
revolutionary pseudonym Koba,
which was the name of George and Robin
Hood type figure for the next two years.
He worked as a clerk at the
titlist metrological observatory.
During this time he became involved in
organizing strikes and writing articles
for Socialists newspapers.
He also became skills as
making revolutionary speeches.
In 1901 he relocated to the
and coastal town of Patou me.
Then he was encouraged by
vrs DLP to start up on rest.
He helped to organize a strike in an
oil refinery which led to him being in
prisons for this.
He spent 18 months in jail and was then
deported to Siberia over the next 12
years.
Stalin,
he was arrested six times each time.
He managed to escape and returns the
West often traveling on forged documents.
He was arrested for the final time in
February of 1913 when was the exile to
Tara Hantske the most
inhospitable part of Siberia.
He was there for four these years.
They hardened him and they made him
cynical in 1986 stone in marriages.
First wife Carto is funny.
Z.
That's Sun Yaakov was born.
The following.
Yeah.
Stolen was often absent,
busy inciting unrest.
As a result,
his wife and sons or little of him can't
say died of typhus in December of 1907
at the age of 22 there's a funeral stolen.
Declasse this creature
softened my heart of stone.
She has died and it's wither have died.
My last warm feelings for humanity stolen,
ignored his son who was brought
up by his in law in later years.
Stalin ordered the arrest and
execution of much of caught his family,
including her brother Alexander,
who had introduced stolen Ricaurte in
1911 style and father to son by his lands
lady while living in a
remote Georgia and village.
The by constant team never had
any contact with his father.
In 1983 the RSD LP is
split into two factions.
Bolshevik ans Menshevik stolen was an
admirer of the writings of the revolution.
Vladimir Lenin,
and aligned himself with
the Bolshevik cause,
his work to undermine the Mensheviks
and his involvement in a number of
burglaries to raise funds
for the Bolsheviks brought
him to Lennon's attention.
Mm.
Lenin was impressed with Scotland
calling him the wonderful Jordan.
In 1912 he appointed him to the
Bolshevik Central Committee.
It was at this time that stolen drops is
Georgia and alias Koba and took on the
name Stalin,
meaning man of steel.
The outbreak of war in 1914 accelerated
the collapse of San Nicholas.
The second is rule to
think on the eastern front,
sends the large loss of
areas of territories,
Germany,
along with food shortages
and economic hardship,
took its toll on Russia's
fragile infrastructure.
Protests and strikes grew in intensity
over the next three years and finally on
march the 15th 1917
the Russian parliament,
the Duma forced a provisional governance,
protests and strikes.
They grew in intensity.
Over the next three years.
Finally,
on march the 15th 1917
the Russian parliament,
the Duma formed a provisional government
that same day saw Nicholas' abdicated
the 304 year Romanov Dynasty was that
an ends a year later and ordered the
merger of the entire Romanov family,
the provisional government,
the socialist,
it's mainly the Mensheviks
now ran the country.
The dual power was necessary
as the government needed
the support of the Soviets
who felt unprepared to
take on full power Stalin.
He was still living in Siberia
in x solid during the revolution.
He returns to live in Petrograd.
Well,
he took over the editorship of
the Bolshevik newspaper profit,
which means truth.
The Bolsheviks were a
minority party and stolen,
decided to cooperate with the provisional
government in order to bolster the
parties popularity.
When Lenin returned from European exile,
he marched the revolution
and it's condemned.
The new government has imperialistic
and no better from the old regime.
He sends it stolen for
his constellate acid.
You towards it.
As a result,
styling toughened his stance
not only against the government,
it was against other socialist parties.
In July of 1917,
protests against the provisional
government's broke out.
Leading Bolsheviks were arrested but not
Stalin who was considered of listened
importance.
Stalin hid Lennon and helped him
disappear into Finland in late October.
Then resends Patrick grads and,
uh,
just an immediate seizure of power.
However,
it moderates within the
party advised restraint,
stolen,
surprisingly sided with them.
Then it however pressed on,
on October the 23rd amazing was health
in which it was voted to undertake an
armed uprising.
Two days later,
the Bolsheviks armed wing led by Leon
Trotsky took control of Petra grasp.
The provisional government was overthrown.
The Soviets had seized power lending,
instituted the new government,
the council of People's Commerce Arts
Starlin was appointed the people's
commissar of nationalities across Russia.
Group's supposed to,
Lennon's new autocracy joined forces to
remove the Bolshevik governments as the
Russians have war broke out.
Stalin was appointed a political commissar
and it's put in charge of the defense
of the city of Sanford sin.
This is the city that would
ultimately become Stalingrad.
He frequently clashed with Trotsky who
had been appointed his military superior.
He wants him prison's a group of Trotsky
supporters on a leaky bodge ans left
them to drown.
The Bolsheviks at this point changed
their name to the Russian Communist Party.
Stalin's rise through this group's ranks
was impressive and he owed it all to
the support of Lennon.
In 1922 Lennon made him general secretary
of the Communist Party's central
committee,
a posty health.
For the rest of his life,
but within a year,
stolen had fallen out with Lennon,
Georgia.
It's Darlene's.
Home State had been promised autonomy
at the time of the revolution,
but that promise had been reneges on
between 1918 and 1921 it's an enjoyed a
period of self rule was in 1922 Lennon
decided to bring us back into the fault.
He wants it the reunion
to be a peaceful one,
but stolen.
He had other ideas.
He cracked down hot,
having the leaders of the
George and rebellion execute
it and then at this point
he was absolutely furious.
But in late 1922 he suffered the first
of a series of strokes which severely
impacted his ability to
command in its estimates,
which was published in November.
He castigated Stalin.
Stalin is too rude.
This defects becomes intolerable
in a secretary general.
That is why I suggest the comrades.
Think of a way of removing stolen from
that post and appointing another man in
his stat.
Months later,
while Lennon was still hospitalized
style in that phone then and his wife,
who he suspected of feeding her husband's
dislike event and subjected her to an
avalanche of abuse referring to her in
the conversation as a syphilitic whore.
When Lennon found out about this,
he was unsurprisingly outraged.
Many people actually believe the stress
of the situation precipitated Lennon's
death.
About 10 months later
after Lennon's death,
Stalin took the lead in
organizing the funeral,
the pairing as the chief pallbearer.
It was at this point that he
initiated the deification of Lenin,
even renaming Petrograd
as Lennon Grasp Stalin.
He used this opportunity to reinvent
himself as the bearer of Lennon's legacy.
From now on to now,
Stalin was to doubt Lennon
stolons main rival was now
Leon Trotsky and his followers.
The leftist Trotskyites in 1925 style
enforced Trotsky to resign as people's
comments off a wall from now on,
anyone who spoke out against the
secretary general worth risking their very
lives when open opposition broke
out in late 1927 it's tremendous,
including Trotsky was
expelled from the party.
Trotsky was exiled to Kazakhstan men.
1919 stolen,
married his second wife.
Now up,
they had two children,
Vaseline born in 1921 and fed liner,
born in 1926 on the evening of November
the eighth 1932 the couple what?
Hosting a party to celebrate the 50th
anniversary of the October Revolution.
They often argued,
and this occasion it was no
difference and that edge,
the accused or husbands of being
inconsiderate towards that,
he responded by humiliating
her in front of their guests.
He flicked cigarettes a
ta and to address her is,
hey you,
the following morning sevens found the
Danish to dads have a gunshot wound to
the head during the rough and civil war,
Lenina daughter,
the acquisition of the peasants,
grain and livestock,
85% of the Soviet population,
they lived off the land.
He had also ordered the
collectivization of farms.
Peasants perceived as better off
the Kulaks were to be destroyed,
killed,
or to port it.
These measures caused widespread
devastation and eventually famine
lines in his mistake.
Man In in 1921 introduced the new
economic policy to try to improve the
situation.
However,
in 1928 style and decided to
reintroduce collectivization,
he aims to achieve this.
Within five years,
anyone who was resisted
was simply put to death.
In December of 1929 stolen announced the
liquidation of the Kulaks as a class or
a peasants were encouraged to denounce
the Kulaks who were to be shot on sight
or if they were lucky,
deported to gulags in Siberia.
Stalin sent out armed forces into the
countryside to force villagers into
collectives.
Many of the people had no
knowledge of agriculture.
The Q legs resulted to slaughtering
their own cattle and destroying their own
equipment rather than see it
disappear into the hands of the state.
Terrible famine.
Then in Syria and Ukraine,
it was the worst with up to 10 million
people dying this time was to be
remembered as the killing of hunger.
Yeah.
At the state offered no help.
In fact,
anyone caught with so much as a handful
of grain was liable to punishment by
death.
At the same time,
there's this,
people were starving to death,
stolen,
exported millions of tons
of vitally needed grain in
1931 stolen stated that the
Soviet Union was a hundred
years behind other countries.
Technologically,
they had 10 years to catch up or they
would be crushed by the rest of the world.
His five year plan saw the
birth of new industrial cities.
Within a decade.
The Soviet Union had indeed some
hostile nations in terms of industrial
developments with the
exception of the United States,
but ordinary Russians.
They fell a new benefit
from stolen successes.
Factory workers became fixated on meeting
unrealistic targets if they failed.
They risked the harshest of punishments.
By 1935 uh,
million citizens were residing
in Stalin's forced labor camps.
The gulags at the 1934 political congress,
a threat to Stalin's absolute power in
merged in the form of Leningrad Party
boss Sergei Kirov stolen,
reacted with a fierce purge of the party.
That's sort of 1,108 that's 56% of the
congress delegates arrested and one third
of them execute it.
On September the first 1934 Sergei
Kirov was assassinated outside the party
officer's in Leningrad,
the alleged assassin,
his wife and his 85 year old's
mother will quickly put to death.
Though many people believe that Stalin
himself was behind this assassination,
stolen,
seized upon this assassination as
the catalyst for the great terror.
He brought in a new law which deprived
of defendants have any defense.
A number of Moscow show trials were
held nearly all of them resulting in the
death penalty over the next three years,
up to 1939 Stalin's purges
became increasingly severe.
He did this for any methodically drawing
up arrest quotas along with numbers to
be shot in each district
still over fulfillments.
If this was encouraged,
people terrified of being denounced got
in with their denunciations first before
the two words announced.
This led to the gulags soon
being overcrowded and new
complexes had to be built
by slave labor.
No one except for Stalin
himself could Trudy and piece.
Many of those in positions of power became
terrified that they too would be next
with some of them are committing suicide
in order to do escape their fate.
The military,
we're not immune to the purchase either.
At the same time that
Hitler was taking me over,
Austria stolen was ordering the execution
of his most able military leaders,
those who survived and became paranoid
of one another during 1939 is Hitler's
military muscle flexing pushed Europe
towards war in feared for the safety of
his country.
He looks to Great Britain
as a potential ally,
but prison didn't appear to be
doing much of anything at all.
So when approached by Germany,
it stolen,
didn't hesitate.
He signs a nonaggression pact with Hitler.
It declared simply that the Russian and
German people would not take up arms
against each other.
This took a great deal
of pressure off stolen
and the summer of 1940
headless subjugation of
Europe seemed unstoppable and
less than two weeks is blitzkrieg pans
or armies had rolled through Belgium,
Holland,
and France.
And at this point he began
looking to the east stolen.
However,
couldn't believe that the fewer
up would go back on his word,
but on June the 22nd 1941
this is exactly what happens.
Nazi troops crossed the Polish
border and invaded the Soviet Union.
The Soviet leader was
caught totally off guard.
Within a month,
German troops were a hundred
miles from Leningrad.
Smolensk fell on July the 16th ends.
By June the 26 just four days
after the attack had begun,
400,000 Soviet soldiers were trapped
as the German tenses and closed around
Minsk,
a key stronghold on route to Moscow.
On June the 29th reports reached Moscow
that the city of mince could fallen.
It was only a week since the
German invasion had begun.
At this rate,
the Germans expected to be
in Moscow within a month.
It was at this point that stolen.
It seemed to finally grasp
the enormity of the disaster.
He raged at his generals,
even reducing the stolid head
of the army's Yaakov to tears,
but then stolen crumbles.
He grinds,
everything's lost.
I give up then and found it all
Allstate and we've screwed it off.
Stolen was driven to his dodger
on the outskirts of Moscow.
He slumped in shock in
his arm chat the next day.
He didn't come into the Kremlin or
responding to phone calls and as absence.
No one dared to make any
decisions or sign any documents.
Suddenly there was a chilling
vacuum at the heart of power.
Historians are divided on
Stalin's mindset during this time.
Some believe that he was
playing a dangerous game
with is in a circle watching
and waiting to see who would try to seize
the reins during this time of crisis.
Others are of the opinion that he
gained close to a nervous breakdown.
What style in faced was
not just military to feet,
but the collapse of everything that
he had worked for within Russia.
Finally,
on June the 30th the politburo
drove ounce to Stalin's dot.
Shah.
They found him still sitting in his arm.
Jack,
he looks up at them,
hi,
good and novice,
and he asked,
why have you come?
He suspected a COO,
but the politburo did not
want to overthrow Stalin.
They wanted him to return to the
Kremlin and take charge of the state.
Defense Committee.
The Soviet wall cabinets are relieved,
stolen,
perhaps that is most
vulnerable ever asked,
can I leave the country to victory?
That may be more deserving candidates.
The reply though,
it came quickly.
There is none more worthy.
Nodding,
stolen,
accepted.
His new role as he began
to regain has enough.
Kiev was overrun by September.
Stalin's advises had begged him
to evacuate the deemed city.
However he refused and more than half
a million people were either killed or
taken prisoner centrally for a scapegoat.
Stolen blames the prisoners themselves.
All prisoners of war he
declared were traitors.
Those who resounds after the war were
sent directly to labor camps when his son,
by his first marriage Yaakov was taken
prisoner of the Nazis approached style
and about trading him for some
of their own and Cynthia replied,
but he had no son by that name.
Yaakov was shot and killed by outside
of the gym and sweat perilously close to
Moscow.
The government's moved 500 miles away,
but Stalin,
he decided to stay attending
a parade on Red Square.
On November the seventh the tank strove
Posten and onto the front lines just 25
miles outside of the city.
The Soviet troops fought valiantly and
the Russian Windsor began to cripple the
German forces in the ends.
The Nazis were unable to solidify their
gains and as they were steadily beaten
back,
stolen.
Also wisely teamed up with the allies
will install in Churchill and Roosevelt.
Matt at the Toronto Conference in 1943
Joseph Stalin was reintroduced to the
west as kindly uncle Joe.
By 1945 the Soviets had won the war,
but the cost,
it was enormous.
More than 25 million Soviets had
died six times as many as in Germany.
Stalin vowed that he would never let
Russia be this vulnerable again of the
Yalta Conference.
In 1945 the allies match to
discuss the postwar world.
Stalin made it clear that eastern
Europe was to remain under his control,
Britain and the USA.
However,
we're not happy with Stalin's
actions in eastern Europe.
Winston Churchill famously declared that
an iron curtain had descended across
the continent and with that,
the Cold War began
back home.
Stalin was even more popular than before.
Grateful Russians hopes that the great
victory overhead low would sweep clean
the misery of the past.
Unfortunately,
however,
the war had Millie
distracted not to changed.
Joseph Stalin,
even though the crowds adored him,
he was convinced that
everyone was out to get him.
Thousands of returning soldiers
were sent to labor camps.
Many Jewish intellectuals and doctors
were tried and killed on style.
The 70th birthday in 1949 images of the
grades leader we're projected into the
skies over Moscow is all
seeing eye was omnipresence,
but the ravages of old age.
We're beginning to catch up
with him after a great feast.
On February the 28th of 1953 Joseph Stalin
had a paralyzing stroke over the next
few days.
He slowly suffocated to death.
Joseph Stalin died on the morning of
March the fifth 1953 his funeral was an
orgy of grief.
Soviet to simply couldn't imagine going
on without their gaunt and father,
but go on.
They did three years after Stalin's death,
his eventual replacement,
Nikita Khrushchev gave an extraordinary
speech at a closed session of the 20th
Party Congress.
He said that while Stalin
had been a great leader,
he had also committed terrible
crimes against the Soviet people.
The Myth of the benevolence protective
comrade leader was finally reveals for
what?
It actually was a terrible lie.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.